Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 11 of my 1hour flipping
challenge. Today we're going to be
flipping Saridomomen drops, Commander
Zilliana. Some of the major drops we're
going to be looking for today is
obviously the Saridomomen sword as well
as the Armadal Crossbow which is
actually on the drop table. Some other
notable uh consumable drops should be
decent as well. Uh but mainly those two
items unfortunately since we're starting
with 30 mil, we cannot afford the
godsord shard. Um, but pretty much
everything else we can and yeah, let's
get started. Okay, so we got one hour on
the clock. We're going to be flipping
Saridomomen drops only for 1 hour. Let's
see how this goes. So, let's hit start
and let's go. Um, so let's just check.
We got 30 mil first. Yeah, 30 mil
exactly. So, we're definitely going to
start with the armadil crossbow. Um, I
never quite understood why that was part
of the Saridomin drop table. We'll go
try mine some of these. One of these to
be precise.
17298k. Sure. We'll just try buying one
of these. Um. Oh boy. I really didn't
think that would instantly
buy. Okay.
Well, that's
interesting. All right. Well, let's go
have a look at some other items while
we're waiting to see if this is actually
going to sell at all. Okay. Okay, so she
has a bunch of drops. I don't know if
we're going to do the Sarah Domen
sword. I'm just going to check the
margin. It's not super expensive item.
1397. Sold it for 1320k. That's pretty
good. And we'll start with like four or
something. Leave us a bit of money left
over. Whoa, Renar seeds have tanked it.
What the
hell? Why are these so low? All right,
Renar seeds
13827. I guess we'll do that. So cheap
to buy Renar seeds now. My god, I'm
assuming Renar weeds have gone down as
well. Magic
seed
108 106. Uh, we could do the magic seed.
Wow, these are
expensive. Start with 20. It's a really
good margin. all our
runes and we bought all the Renar seeds
and another 100 of these. We'll cap this
out and it looks like we actually have
gotten the Seridoman sword. That's
exciting. Oh, we sold our arm crossbow.
That's good. Okay. Okay, perfect. Okay,
Saridomomen sword. What did we Oh, did
we write it
down? Don't think so. So, let's just put
it in for
1380k. Okay, perfect. And we've sold the
armal cross, but that's good. So,
17 294 is the high
price. And we'll see what we can buy for
the low price. Armadill crossbow.
Put it in for
1760k. How
about Okay, we bought all those magic
seeds quite quickly actually. Put them
in for
108. Okay, so we've sold all the seeds.
We'll claim that money and put these in
as well. Wow, I instantly sold them.
Okay. Okay, we b our Sarah sword.
Actually, that's good. Now, I just have
to make sure we actually can sell
them. Oh, I think I just sold that.
Okay. I feel like someone must have just
checked the margin maybe. Um, incoming
about to get under undercut, but see
something sneaky.
1373K. So, assuming he checked the
margin, he's going to put it down to
1374K probably. and then I'll just
instantly undercut him. But either way,
that is a 50k
profit. Not going to do too crazy to
begin with. We'll start with 500. Oh, we
sold a Sarah Domen sword. Nice. That is
another 50k right there. Pretty much
anyway. So, we'll take the money back
there. And we bought another one.
Awesome. Put back in for 1373k.
There's a last Sarah do sword gone
through already. So I think we're going
to buy some more of
these and another three I guess while
we're waiting. Actually very good margin
on Lun right now. Um yeah 8GP that's
quite good. Sell that for
239. And we got another Saridomomen
sword. Uh we're going to have to start
Lowering these down maybe a little bit
because we do need to sell
them.
1372k. Um, and yeah, we got another
Seridoman sword sold. So, that's pretty
nice. Can't remember how many. I think
we've done three. This will be our
fourth flip. And I think we have eight
in total. Not quite sure about that.
[Music]
571. 261. That's quite good as well.
Death rune. Definitely going to do that.
Don't quite have enough, I don't think,
for all of them. And we got another
Sarah sword. Quite awesome.
1372k. Uh, so we have three of these to
sell once. Okay, we got four of these to
sell. Okay, we can't buy any more of
these unfortunately for now.
I know there's a limit of
70 and that's pretty much our limit.
Okay, we bought an armal crossbow.
17270. Let's see if we can sell it for a
bit
more. 17370
maybe. Okay, we've sold a sod diamond
sword. Nice. It's another quick sale for
that. Oh, wow. Another one sold I
believe. Oh, no. Yeah. Yeah, two sold.
We just happened to. Wow, that was
quick. And we've sold all the law runes.
That's nice. I got 9 GP on that and
10,000 rune. That's probably 90k almost.
And why do we have a SE? Oh my god, we
put a buy offer again. What keeps
happening? Okay. And we bought a good
amount of the death runes already, so
we'll sell those
off. Buying them for 261. can sell them
for 267. That's pretty decent. It's all
gone. Perfect. Um, okay. We could do the
loop in two halves of key actually, if
they're decent. Anyway, start with
100 and finish this first, but we did
sell the armor of the crossbow, which is
cool. And 100 of those. Okay, armor
crossbow we made 30k on. That's pretty
[__] Let's go try buying it for lower.
Try buying it for 17200k.
Actually very impressed with the runes
so
far. 10,000 H runes. Get that going.
799. Sure. Do 200 to start with. We can
always buy more. I think we're going to
raise maybe
1750. Even though it's not a huge margin
relatively,
like it's still going to
help. And it's not like I have a lot of
other items I can do with the money. So,
this might be the
best. What was there a berserker ring on
the ground? What the
[__] Uh, hello. What's going
on? Remind me to never do these stupid
diamonds again.
do a thousand and see how that
goes. Stupid magic seed not doing much.
Okay, we all the nature runes. That was
pretty quick. Uh, flip them for a 2GP
profit. Not too
bad. Well, it's kind of kind of okay, I
guess. Okay, we've sold all the nature
runes, which is kind of
nice. Whoops. And rune darts. Yeah. No,
not doing this. This is going to take
way too long. No chance. Okay, we bought
another one of these armored little
crossbows. Let's see if we can flip them
for a bit more.
Maybe
17310k. Can we at least get 40k from
this? There we go. Sold the armal
crossbow for
17310. See if we can get some more of
these in.
Took us almost the entire time to figure
out the
margin, which is not great to be honest,
but uh still that was a Wow. Instantly
bought it. Oh my
god. 17
310k. Wow, that was insanely quick. But
uh yeah, that's that's good. I mean,
that was another 40k, I guess.
13605. Yeah, we'll see how that goes. Oh
[__] there's rune arrows. Didn't even
notice that. Ah, that would have been
easy. Ah, we're not going to lose any
money even if we don't manage to sell
them, which is probably not super likely
with this much time left. Just bought
all 100 Runite bars all at once. What
are we selling them for? 13790.
There they go. The rune arrows. That was
expected, but very quick, which is nice.
All right, good news everybody. We have
sold the armadillo
crossbow for a 30k profit. Whatever. I
will take that. Runate bars. We actually
sold as well, which is nice. Not
actually sure how much we made on that.
Now, all we have left is all this crap
down here, which we'll hopefully sell
soon. If not, we will have to dump it.
We only have 3 minutes and 30 seconds
left approximately. And we have sold the
grimyars and the crystal keys, which is
nice. All we have left is the magic
seeds. And then we get to kind of see
how much money we actually made. Okay
guys, we are down to 30 seconds left. I
don't think these magic seeds are
selling, but that's okay. We will dump
them and see how much money we actually
get. Uh, well, we definitely made it
over 30 mil, which is nice. Not really
sure how much I made this episode. It
felt like I got a lot of flips in, but
none of them were for a very big margin.
I would say five or
600k. Not really sure to be honest. Uh
really if the margins have been bigger,
I would have made quite a bit of money.
But there we go. Timer's done. We'll
take these magic seeds out and see what
we end up getting. Pop them in for 106
maybe and just get those sold. Okay, we
sold them
for 106 219. probably lost one can each.
Oh well, not too bad. All right, let's
run over here and see how much we
weighed from one hour of flipping
Saridomomen drops. We have
made
562k. Um, so not too bad. Definitely not
as good as the Barrows items. Although I
think the only reason is that the
barrows were that much better is just
because of luck. Like the margins were
just better. I think these items could
work quite well. The Saratomomen sword
flipped very quickly. It's quite a nice
item. Definitely the best item of the
the episode for sure. Armor crossbow.
I'm sure if it had like a two or 300k
margin on it, it would have been great,
but um fortunately did not. Um but not
much I can do about that. But uh yeah,
that's about it, guys. I hope you guys
enjoyed and we'll see you guys in the
next episode.
[Music]